time now for pft on yahoo sports peter
king and mike florio looking at the big
stories in the nfl we're getting closer
and closer to playoff time peter let's
take a look at some of the surprise
contenders some of the teams that we
maybe don't expect or didn't expect to
be in the mix that are actually going to
make it who are the the first teams that
come to mind for you when we think about
surprise contenders this season
well cleveland being nine and three you
thought that cleveland was going to turn
the corner a little bit this coming
season or this season mike but being
nine and three
and going to tennessee and really for
two plus quarters destroying that
defense that surprises me i am not
surprised so much by the dolphins really
but i'm surprised that uh they've won
two-thirds of their games
and and and i only say that because i
think they have had some unexpectedly
uh surprising dominant wins
winning by 26 points in san francisco
especially against a battered san
francisco team i thought was a huge
surprise and they're playing well even
though tuatanga veloa is not playing
particularly well and then the last one
of course i think would be the new york
giants um
you know talking to people they're
talking to leonard williams this week
you know they're they're
rising star defensive lineman i think
one of the things that they appreciate
about the environment
with the giants this year and now
is that
a it's all football b they listen to
nobody other than joe judge you know
they have really shut off they have no
idea what's on the back page of the
daily news they just don't care and i
think that's one of the good things that
judge has done i think he's got a rested
team
entering the home stretch of the
playoffs and mike i think they're going
to win that division
that mark columbo firing from a few
weeks ago could have gone either way for
joe judge they haven't lost since then
and and it has proven to be a good
decision by him that has helped bring
the team together and in that same
division peter after what washington did
in pittsburgh on monday night to get to
five and seven now the giants have the
tiebreaker by virtue of the head-to-head
sweep of washington but
you have to take washington seriously
alex smith arguably the best quarterback
in the division i would say he is right
now given the ones who are playing
obviously if everyone's healthy dak
prescott is but alex smith clearly the
comeback player of the year you had said
if he even takes one snap he's the
comeback player of the year at this
point they should just give it to him
but i think washington is a team that we
never would have included in the mix for
potential playoff qualification and
they're going to be right there with the
giants and the best news is both of
those teams are five and seven maybe one
of those teams gonna win three out of
the last four and get to eight and eight
to avoid the embarrassment of a losing
team hosting a playoff game
i think the amazing thing about
washington and the giants if you think
about it mike
they have each won
two or more
wins than
dallas and philadelphia
and and when you think about that
they're not just marginally better than
dallas and philadelphia the two teams
that everyone was convinced would be on
the bottom of this division are on the
top of the division and deservedly so
carson wentz is basically and the
offensive line have taken the eagles
down with them
and in dallas obviously they were
hurting before
dak prescott got hurt now it's even
worse than that but there's no doubt in
my mind that one of those two teams wins
the division and both of those teams are
playing their best when it's most
important
what do you think the raiders are gonna
do do you think they're gonna make it i
mean they have beaten the chiefs and the
saints arguably team number one and two
in everyone's power rankings this week
now if the steelers have lost do you
think the raiders are even gonna make it
i don't think the raiders are gonna make
it and i i think they've lost too many
games marginal games they should have
lost sunday
um but
that loss to atlanta i think is going to
is gonna doom them mike really i i'd
love to see you make it because they're
a fun team to watch i don't see it
happening
that's it for this edition of pft on
yahoo sports thanks for your time we'll
see you next time
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports